in some point let's say computers can
understand 300 alleges can fluently
communicate and converse I have not run
into a person who can speak 300
languages and not only machine can
fluently communicate in a converse but
can comprehend understand and the
learner and the reason and can really
finish all the PhD courses in all the
subjects the knowledge acquisition
reasoning is beyond any ones individual
capability when that moment is here you
can think about how intelligent that AI
is going to be you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it I'm your host Gretchen Hughes
Inga
[Music]
when was the last time you had a
meaningful conversation with your
computer and felt like it truly
understood you well if doctors you dong
Wong a Microsoft technical fellow and
head of Microsoft's speech and language
group is successful you will and if his
track record holds true it'll be sooner
than you think
on today's podcast dr. Wong talks about
his role as Microsoft's chief speech
scientist gives us some insight details
on the latest milestones in speech and
language technology and explains how
mastering speech recognition translation
and conversation will move machines
further along the path from perceptive
AI to cognitive AI and that much closer
to truly human intelligence that and
much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast joo
hyung-hwan
welcome to the podcast thank you you are
a Microsoft technical fellow in the
speech and language group and you lead
Microsoft's spoken language efforts so
we're going to talk in depth about these
in a bit but first as the company's
chief speech scientist give us a general
view of what you do for a living why you
do it what get you up in the morning
well what we do is really make sure we
have the best speech and and language
technology that can be used to empower a
wider range of scenarios the reason we
have group to do that is really I fear
that you know this is not only the most
natural way for people to communicate as
we're doing right now but it's a really
the hardest AI challenges we're facing
so that's what we do trying to really
drive breakthrough deliver this awesome
services on our cloud as your services
and make sure we are satisfying a wide
range of customers both inside Microsoft
and outside of Microsoft there are three
things to Beadie if you want to frame
this whole thing yeah the first we have
the host power to really drive speech
recognition accuracy to drive the
naturalness of our synthesis effort to
make sure translation quality is
accurate when you translate from English
to Chinese or French or German so
there's really a lot of science behind
that
make sure the accuracy naturalness
latency they really would a class so
that's one the second one is really we
not only provide technology we deliver
services down assure that from office to
Windows Cortana they all depend on the
same cloud services and we also have
edge devices like our speech device SDK
so we want to make sure the speech on
the edge and the cloud they are really
delivered in the modern fashion that's a
platform in the cloud and embedded so
that's the second the platform is modern
the third one is really to show our love
to the customer because we'll have wider
range of customers worldwide we want to
really delight and make sure our
customer experience using speech in
translation is top-notch yeah plus it
actually really three key things I do AI
horsepower modernize our platform in the
cloud and on the edge and love our
customers well and you've got a lot of
teams working in these groups to tackle
each of these pillars we might call them
yes we have teams worldwide as well yeah
and so the diversity is amazing because
we are really trying to address the
language barriers yeah trying to remove
the language of areas so we do have
teams in China we have teams in Germany
in Israel in India and in the US of
course so we really work around the
globe trying to a deal with this
language challenges so I want to start
by quoting you to set the stage for our
conversation today you said speech and
language is the crown jewel of a I so
unpack that for us mm-hmm well we can
think in the scale of humans evolution
and at some point the language was born
not accelerate humans evolution if you
think about all the animals on this
planet you know there are animals
running faster than humans you can see
better tonight
stronger yeah they can actually hear
better smell better only we humans have
the language we can organize better we
can describe in science fiction internal
we can really organize ourselves create
a constitution so if you look at the
humans it is speech in a language that
set us apart from other animals for
artificial intelligence speech and
language would drive the evolution of AI
just like it did to humans that's why
it's the crown jewel of AI and it's a
tough one to crack
yeah there's a whole philosophical
discussion on that topic alone but it
leads to some interesting questions
about you know if you're wildly
successful with machine language what
are these machines so that's just
actually you know set our imagination
right and some point let's say computers
can understand 300 languages can
fluently communicate and converse I have
not run into a person who can speak 300
languages and not only machine can
fluently communicate in a converse but
can comprehend understand and the
learner and the reason and they can
really finish all the PhD courses in all
the subjects the knowledge acquisition
reasoning is beyond anyone's individual
capability when that moment is here you
can think about how intelligent that AI
is going to be is this something you
envision yes do we want that yes
I think this world would be much better
place I was in Japan just a few weeks
ago carry Microsoft translator on my
mobile devices I was able to really
communicate with Japanese who do not
speak Chinese or English
he's already their Microsoft translator
can speak the language I do not speak
and helped me to be more productive well
was in Japan so I'm all about that just
scares me a little bit to think about a
machine
we weren't first were not last or just
next you know they are two level of
intelligence the first level is really
perceptive intelligence that is the
ability to see to hear to smell then the
high level is cognitive intelligence
then it's the ability to reason to learn
and to acquire knowledge most of the AI
breakthroughs we have today they are in
the perceptive level such as speech
recognition speech synthesis computer
vision but this high-level reasoning and
the knowledge acquisition cognitive
capability is still far from being close
to humans level right and what I'm
excited about the translation it is
really something between perceptive
intelligence and cognitive intelligence
and the fact that we actually able to
really view the success on the
preceptory intelligence and expand into
cognitive intelligence is quite their
journey and I do not know when we're
gonna reach that milestone but that one
is coming just as a matter of time want
to take 50 years but I think it is going
to happen we'll have to come back for
another podcast to talk about that
milestone because we're going to talk
about a couple milestones in a minute
but first I want to do a little bit of
backtracking because you've been around
for a while and you started in Microsoft
Research right about the time Rick
Ratched was setting the organization up
and speech was one of the first groups
that was formed and according to MSR
lore the goal of the group was to make
speech mainstream so give us a brief
history of speech at MSR how is the
research gone from not mainstream in
those early take risks and look far out
days to being a presence in nearly every
Microsoft product today before I joined
Microsoft Research I was also on the
faculty and the CMU in Pittsburgh so big
rush it was a professor there I was a
junior faculty member so I was doing my
research mostly and a CMU on speech
Microsoft reached out and they wanted to
set up speech group so I moved actually
on the first day of 1993 after New
Year's break I flew from Pittsburgh to
Seattle and started that journey and
never changed so that was the beginning
of Microsoft speech we were the research
group that really started working on
bringing speech to the developers right
so not just blue sky research so we
licensed technology from CMU that's how
we started so we're very grateful to CMU
is pioneering research in this area so
we were the research group and but we
delivered the first speech EAP is a P on
Windows 95 as a research group we were
pretty proud of that because usually
research is doing only blue sky research
well not only did blue sky research
continue to push the envelope continue
to improve the recognition accuracy but
we also worked with windows brought that
the technology to windows developer so
sappy was the first especia PR in the
industry on Windows and that was really
quite a journey and then I eventually
left research join the product group I
took that him and it was also an
exceptional Microsoft speech research
group came with me
went to the Prada group so this has been
really fascinating 27 years experience
and Microsoft I stopped doing speech
after 2004 after we shipped speech
server and I started many different
things including running the incubation
for research as a start-up yeah and I
also worked as architect for Satya
Nadella when he was running being ok and
then when Harry was 1 in research and
technology group and was helped him
incubating wider range of AI projects
from a foundational pieces like a GPU
cluster project filling the deep
learning toolkit since ek of course
speech research all the way to the high
end the solution that cosmic air
intelligence about three years ago I had
the privilege to return to run a
combined a speech and language group so
basically we were able to consolidate
all those resources working on speech
and the translation and that was the
story really you know the journey of my
experience fascinating 27 years where
the speech and language live right now
so as I said we moved back and forth
multiple times between research and
front a group but now we are sitting in
cloud an AI group this is a proper group
we're part of this cloud services and
would provide company-wide
and the industry-wide speech and
translation services we also have a
speech in dialogue of research they are
really operating in Agra research group
yeah they all researchers in a team and
what the big has been saying tech
transfer is the full contact sport we
are not just you know a full contact
spot with one body spot so it's actually
a very exciting group was a group of
very talented very innovative people
so it's still forward-thinking in the
research both for the thinking and well
granted we have to be grounded to
deliver services from infrastructure to
cost of serving and we also have to be
standing high to see the future to
define what is the solution that the
people need and people want even though
the solution may not have existed and
they may not know what it is and this
moment
[Music]
well let's talk about some specific
research milestones that you've been
involved in they're really interesting
three areas you've been involved in
conversational speech recognition
machine translation and conversational
Q&A so let's start with the recognition
in 2016 you let a team that reached
historical human parity in transcribing
conversational speech tell us about this
what was it part of how did it come
about so in 2016 we reach the humor
parity on the broadly used switch board
conversational transcription cast that
task has been used in the research
community and the industry probably over
ten years and 2017 we defined the human
parity milestone so we're not competing
with only one single person
well competing with a group of people to
transcribe the same cast so I would say
2017 is really historical moment in
comparison to a group of people
transcribing the same task Microsoft
speech stack are to perform all four
teams combined together when I challenge
our research group nobody thought that
was even feasible but in less than two
years amazingly who had the conviction
and resource and the focus magic indeed
happen so that was actually a fantastic
moment for the team for science for the
technology stack there was the first
human priority milestone for my personal
professional career so I want to go in
the weeds a little bit on this because
this is interesting what you say in two
years nobody thought it was possible and
then you did it tell us a little more
about the technical aspects of how you
accomplish this so if you look in the
history of speech research and the
speech group pioneered many
breakthroughs that got to be used by
others let's take translations example
so even for speech in early 70s
the speech recognition used the more
transition I like a rule-based approach
export system and IBM Watson research
pioneered statistic speech recognition
using hidden Markov model using you know
statistic language model they really
pushed the envelope and advanced the
field so that was a great moment
what's the same group of IBM speech
researchers they borrowed the same idea
from speech recognition applied that to
translation they we wrote translation
history really advanced the quality of a
translation substantially and after
hidden Markov model it was deep learning
that started with speech recognition
neuro speech recognition and once again
translation mara the same thing with the
neural machine translation and also
advanced so you can see the mirror of
using technology switch people pioneered
actually speech guys have been doing
this you know his systematic
benchmarking funded by topper very
rigorous evaluation that really changed
how science and engineering could be
evaluated so there are many broad
lessons from speech technology community
that could have been used broadly beyond
speech so we got trained to deal with
tough problems
it's no wonder the same group of people
could have achieved this historic
milestone well let's talk about another
human parity milestone the automatic
Chinese to English news translation for
the WMT 2017 task and I had a rule
Manassas on the show to talk all about
that but I'd love your perspective on
whether and how this is kind of goes
back to what we talked about at the
beginning whether in how you think
machines can now compared to traditional
human translation services and why this
work is an important breakthrough for
barriers between people and cultures so
the second human project breakthrough
from my team is equally excited
as I said transcribing switchboard
conversational speech is great milestone
but there is ability and a very low
level and the perceptive AI level right
translation is a task that is between
perceptive AI and the cognitive AI of
course
translation is a harder task and nobody
believed we could have achieved this so
we set a goal in five years let's see if
we can achieve translation human parity
and the sentence by sentence basis so I
wanted to put that the condition here
when human not you and me translate we
look in the whole paragraph we have the
broad contacts we do a better job
so we limited ourselves because for the
probably used wmg which is just a news
translation measured on the sentence
personal level is broadly open research
probably a benchmark even for that one
we thought you could have taken five
years so we apply the same principle
build on the success we had on
transcribing switchboard speech
recognition but this time we actually
went one step beyond we partner with
Microsoft Research Group in Beijing
because he's a Chinese to English
translation so across Pacific multiple
teams in Microsoft Research Asia worked
together days and nights amazingly this
group of people surprised everyone we
delivered this in less than a year
reaching him parity and historical
translation level better than
professional people on the same task as
measured by our scientists so this time
really we did something magic I'm very
proud of the team and we're proud of the
collaboration well another super
interesting area that I'd love to talk
about with you is some what you call
coca hmm and that's coq a conversational
QA so obviously we're talking about
computers having this conversation with
us question and answer tell us about the
work that's going on in this
human and perhaps most difficult of
tasks and speech recognition technology
so this task is pioneered by Stanford
researchers and it's even one step
closer to cognitive AI this is a really
machine reading comprehension task with
conversation with dialogue about the
task let's say you read a paragraph then
we challenge the reader to answer
correctly with the sequence questions
that they are related for example if you
read the paragraph or part of Bill Gates
the first question could have been who
is the founder of Microsoft the second
question could be related to the first
one how old is the person when the
person started now you could have say
and when the person retired how old was
he so now the contacts relevancy is the
harder than simple mission meeting
comprehension because there's a sequence
of related question you have to answer
given the contacts so for this latest
breakthrough and I have to give credit
mostly to our colleagues in Beijing
research lab we have been pioneering
this working together using share the
resources and the infrastructure is just
amazing I'm so impressed with the
agility and the speed we have to achieve
this amazing conversation question
answering challenge so the leading
researchers there are in Beijing who
played a great and supporting role
helping Microsoft once again be the
first to achieve human party and this
broadly watched AI task
nobody believed anyone could have
achieved this conversational puny human
priority in such a short time and so we
thought it might take two years once
again we broke historical record well
we've talked a little bit about the more
technical aspects of what you're doing
and how you're doing this so on this
last one
are there any other methodologies or
techniques that you brought to the table
to conquer this QA task so Microsoft has
accumulated 30 years of research and
experiences in AI write the natural
language group in Beijing they have been
doing this in us 20 years and have a
criminal laws of talents a lot of
experiences and we basically use the
deep learning and transfer learning also
we build our success on top of the whole
community for example Google they
delivered this is a fascinating
technology called the bird and it's not
an acronym
yes its Akron is embedding technology we
built the success on top of that
expanded that that's how we achieved the
human parakeet breakthrough so it's
really a reflection of a collective
community and I thought about the
collaboration between Microsoft Research
in Asia and the our team in the u.s.
actually this is a great example of
collaboration of the whole industry
[Music]
on the heels of everything that could
possibly go right and it's pretty
exciting what you've described to us in
this podcast we do have to address what
could possibly go wrong if you're
successful but you want to enable
computers to listen hear speak translate
answer questions basically communicate
with people does anything about that
keep you up at night yes absolutely
my worries really someday
humans can be too dependent on AI and AI
will never be perfect
ai would have a unique sort of biases so
I worry about that unconscious influence
right so how to deal with that is really
a broad societal issue that we have to
be aware and we have to address because
just like anyone if you have my
assistant you depend on you absolutely
know how much that assistant can you
influence you change your gender change
your opinion and a high one day is going
to play the same role AI will be biased
and how do we deal with that is my top
concern yeah if everything goes well
that is really you know a top issue we
have to deal with we have to learn how
to deal with it we do not know because
we're not there yet so what kinds of
Design Thinking are you bringing to this
as you build these tools that can speak
and listen and converse because one of
the biggest things is that human ability
to impugn qualities to something that's
not human I think just you know they are
enough responsible people walking on AI
and the good news is that we're not
there yet right so we have time to work
together to deal with that and make sure
a is going to really serve mankind not
to destroy mankind so that's my
top worried what keeps me awake but my
short-term war is really is not good
enough not yet and people as Bill Gates
used to say always overestimate what you
can do in the short term and
underestimate the impact in the long
term for this case we cannot
underestimate the long term impact down
to my last own okay it's story time
mmm good tell us a bit about your life
and what's your story what got you
interested in research particularly
speech and language technology research
and what was your path to MSR good I was
a graduate student in Beijing's Tsinghua
University at that time my first
computer was Apple - so because you know
Chinese language is not easy to type so
it was very cumbersome so that necessity
brought me to speech recognition my
dream and that time was as a graduate
student in changhua actually was in AI
being AI Qing was you know graduate
school yeah was fantastic would have you
know so many professors and the faculty
members who had a long term vision and
set up the pioneering environment forced
to explore and experiment with so I
finished my master degree I was in the
ph.d program and I have been working on
speech recognition since 82 as I was
involved admitted to Chinua in 1982 that
dream to make it easier for people to
really communicate with machines never
disappeared so I have been working on
this for over thirty years
even though and Microsoft for a short
period of time I stepped out speech when
I was here doing something related so I
really thought this was a fascinating
story so I got some personal really
interesting stories as I said you know
it was hard to type in
nice William was under Ching hua
university and I didn't finish my PhD
and the Chinua I went to University of
Edinburgh okay in Scotland and I did
finish my PhD there but my personal pain
point when I first landed in Edinburgh
was really and I learned English mostly
American English in China it wasn't that
good because it wasn't my native
language but the lesson into Scottish
the professor talking was always
challenging but I was so grateful PBC
had closed captioning Oh finally so I
really learned my Scottish English from
watching BBC and I have to say that
automatic captioning technology is
available on Microsoft PowerPoint today
and that journey of personal pain points
to what office powerpoint teams can
bring together is fascinating and
personally extremely rewarding yeah I'm
so grateful to see the technology I have
to walk down is going to help many other
people who are attending Scottish
universities you know a rule talked
about that PowerPoint yeah service and
he was starting about people who had
hearing disabilities you give it a whole
new it's a much broader because the
language barrier is is always there not
that everyone is as fluent and by hosts
many visitors almost in every year I'm
hosting my University MBA students and
they all learn English but the ability
to converse and lesson simply is not as
good as native people here so the simple
fact that we are able to provide the
captioning on the PowerPoint
presentation help with all of them yeah
to learn and understand them much better
so this is actually a fairly broad
scenario without even translating just
the fact you have captioning where he
has a communication right
and you know we talked earlier about the
different languages and we talked a
little bit about dialects but we didn't
really talk about accents within
language I mean even in the United
States you go to various parts of the
country and have a more difficult time
understanding even from your own country
just because of the accent that's why
I'm a Scottish English is that good
story and I hope I still have a little
bit of Scottish accent I well at the end
of every podcast I give my guests the
last word and since you're in human
language technologies it's particularly
apropos for you
now's your chance just say whatever you
want to our listeners who might be
interested in enabling computers to
converse and communicate what are they
to put boots on for what can speech and
language this is really the crown jewel
of AI you know and there's no more
challenging pasture than this one in my
opinion especially if you move from
perceptive AI to cognitive AI to get the
ability to reason to understand to
acquire knowledge by reading by
conversing is this you know such a
fundamental area that can improve
everyone's life improve everyone's
productivity make this world a much
better place without the language
barriers without the communication
barriers without understanding barriers
you don't wan thank you so much for
joining us on the podcast today it's
been fantastic my pleasure
[Music]
to learn more about dr. judith wong and
the science of machine speech and
language visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]